[Music]
everyone thanks for joining to listen to
our talk which will be about how to
analyze gaming data using Google cloud I
will cover the theory behind some of the
Google cloud products and services and
I'll then hand over to Luke from a
probable we'll talk about what they've
built in terms of real-world data
analytics pipelines this solution that
they built has also been open sourced so
you can go check it out afterwards in an
era of free-to-play an online
multi-player games data has become
crucial to understanding and improving
your game the ability to collect analyze
and derive insights from data has
effects across the entire value chain of
your game and this is everything from
being able to create better game levels
through play testing using a eyes that
have been trained on the behavior of
real-world gamers to improving
monetization outcomes through better
customer segmentation and tailored
offers organizations also want to be
able to share data across the different
units from the game developers to the
marketing teams and this needs to be
done in a secure manner data is
typically stored in a data warehouse
however talking to various teams in the
industry we've discovered that they
struggle to achieve their goals of
analyzing the gaming events and data
that you collect this is mainly due to
challenges around the scalability and
cost of legacy data warehouse solutions
for example those solutions struggle to
handle the exponential growth of data
that we're seeing in the industry it's
also more and more difficult to
integrate between the various external
sources that you pull from and with more
and more games moving to real-time
telemetry feeds being able to analyze
ingest would process those becomes even
harder so really the question is is
there a platform out there that can
scale to the needs of your game everyone
my name is olivier van got'em and i work
at google cloud as a customer engineer
we'll now dig a bit deeper into the
topic of data analytics and look at one
of our key products in this area and
that product is bigquery Auclair native
data warehouse it grows fully managed
and serviced and offers
everything that you'd expect from a data
warehouse it also has key unique
capabilities such as the ability to
ingest and analyze real-time streaming
data bigquery also has a high speed a
memory cache which we call bi engine for
faster reporting and analysis using
tools such as tableau security is also
very important for us on our customers
that is why all data is encrypted at
rest by default however one of the most
exciting capabilities of bigquery is its
built-in machine learning training and
prediction capabilities let's have a
look at those so big UML enables data
analysts to build and deploy machine
learning models on massive datasets
directly inside bigquery using just the
power is sequel big query ml has a
capability of addressing various use
cases for example you're able to segment
customers using k-means clustering
models you can determine a player's a
lifetime value using linear regression
and you can definitely create more funky
complex use cases by training external
tensor flow model somewhere and directly
importing that into bigquery and making
use of it to predict using beaker ml and
sequel so let's have a look in practice
so let's imagine a table in bigquery
that contains game of purchase and
playing time data here we've aggregated
these data points to have a single row
per user ID that contains values for
their total number of game purchases and
total hours of playing time we've been
asked by the marketing team to segment
these users so that we can identify our
most valuable customers to do this I can
use bigquery ml's k-means clustering
model all done again using just a simple
sequel statements I configure the model
to segment our user base into four
categories and on that I pass in the
data from the table that I was showing
previously once the model has been
trained I can check the model evaluation
to validate its output Vickery ml
automatically splits the data we feed
into the training step so that
percent is used to train on all and 20%
is used to test it here we can see that
we've identified the key characteristics
for our four segments so for example
we're going to have our first group
their purchase a few games but play a
lot of them we see a group of people who
purchase a lot of games and then play a
lot of those games then we have a group
who just dabble in video games purchase
very few games and also play them very
little and in the final group which is
the one that I probably belong in which
is I buy a lot of games during sales and
never play them at all
victory is only one piece of Google kind
smart analytics platform Google's
platform enables you to build much
broader data pipelines by connecting
analyzing and visualizing your data
across your applications and systems
this means we bring you the best of
Google in our solutions and we can help
you create a more innovative and
collaborative culture in your
organization the Google Cloud analytics
platform can also be combined with
compute services to build out a
full-blown gaming architecture for
example you can use App Engine and
firestore to manage user profiles and
hands and logins and log outs you can
also use kubernetes engine to host a
matchmaking service and your game
servers and finally you can from those
systems
above send all of the events and
telemetry directly into bigquery for our
analysis as I mentioned for a real world
example I'm now going to hand over to
Luke who will talk about what they are
doing and improbable hi guys and so as
all you said I'm Luke I'm a data
scientist and improbable so first a
little bit about us who we are and what
we do we provide better ways to make
multiplayer games and help multiplayer
developers meet any challenge so how do
we do that we've got several services
some of which include for instance
managed hosting and orchestration of
your game servers we also have
networking products that could allow you
to combine multiple game engines you can
do more than what a single engine can
currently do you've got online services
such as analytics and I'm going to be
talking about that one in particular
today and then we still have other
development tools as well as everything
from advice and support to
Fuko development of your game finally we
now also have three internal game
studios that are building multiplayer
games using their services and products
that I just outlined and our first
internal game called scavengers is gonna
be out there this year to keep an eye
out for that one
so the analytics pipeline and what is it
and why did we build it went out in the
field talking to you Game Studios we
kind of notice that there wasn't an easy
way for them to quickly get going with
analytics and so we kind of set out to
solve that by providing a reference
architecture that is just like a deploy
in your own cloud models it quickly
could get going with analytics and one
of the key tenets that we kept in the
back of our heads was that we wanted to
give data like studios full access of
their own data without any form of
lock-in so the the key principle is you
just deployed in your own cloud all the
data comes in to your own cloud hosting
your own kind of like blob storage and
as at that point you can then decide to
do whatever you want
perfectly with it which could be for
instance using an off-the-shelf LiveOps
or game Analects provider but you still
have the flexibility then so on live
data also utilize any of the m/l or AI
tools provided by google cloud in this
case so why Google cloud and they
provide highly scalable analytics for
instance you can process millions of
events per second with pops-up and data
flow they're very easy to use and a
probable we're big use of kubernetes and
you kind of have this first-class
kubernetes experience when developing on
Google clouds
they're also fully supported by
terraform which is our DevOps templating
a language of choice and they've got
great documentation for all the breaks
that they provide also with like example
code snippets in various languages so if
you can I want to prototype something
quickly if you just copy paste those get
it to work and then if you think of
something there you can after it and
make the code your own and then in
particular for analytics they've got a
great stack of a IO machine learning
tools so like oli just outlined before
big create ml but if you have many
models that you want to train and deploy
in production you could use the AR
platform of that for instance so
ingesting data using the analytics
pipeline the big picture is as follows
on the left hand side we have things
that emit events they could be pcs
consoles mobile devices game events from
other sources systems or whatnot
those posts or send all the events
it expired line and the goal of the
analytics pipeline is just to capture
and persist and organize all of that
data in your own cloud hosting and that
then kind of makes it ready to be used
by any other service in the future such
as cloud data prep to like prepare for
machine learning models we create a Mel
Auto well etc or just to like analyze
that data with victory and feed it into
reporting systems like tableau looker
etc so the architecture starts with
events there are JSON events that are
posted to a REST API that is a Python 3
application adhering to the flash
programming model it is deployed on
kubernetes engine so that means that if
your demand or the the influx of events
kind of enhances kubja news can auto
scale copies of that like application
like to however much it needs to meet
those requirements so it's kind of like
horizontally scalable when those events
arrive it kind of augments them a little
bit between sensor receive timestamp and
then writes new line the limited case on
the blob storage so once all your data
is neatly aggregated in that blob
storage bucket you're kind of done
because you can then use bigquery to
actually query data that's inside of
that bucket in a federated way federated
means that you kind of the data doesn't
live inside of victory but somewhere
else but you can still use sequel
statements on top of data that is in you
learn the limit of JSON in cloud storage
and over time you might notice that ok I
actually have a lot of events coming in
each post request becomes a file in
cloud storage so my queries are slowing
down because have so many files so the
first way you can solve for that is by
using a cloud function that basically
gets invoked whenever a file hits this
bucket and the function gets invoked it
takes the contents of that file from
blob storage and then writes it into
native big furry storage so at that
point if you don't read those like
tables that are in native storage all
your queries kind of benefit from the
native performance of big trees
everything will be super fast again
another way which isn't any open source
repo but we've added ourselves when load
testing this is to add in a batch job so
we've used data flow for this that comes
in every hour and picks up all the
latest small files in the first bucket
and then aggravates them into a second
final resting place but we
have far fewer but much larger files and
if you then query those in a federated
way with big hurry everything will
become much quicker again so and we have
successfully scaled this infrastructure
to ten thousand requests per second at
an average of one server or tank as per
30 seconds which is something that you
can treat yourself based on your
capacity and peak CCU this would support
a peak CCU of about 300,000 and we also
tested this with an average payload of
10 events per requests so this would
equal eight point six billion events per
day so there's two caveats when using
this at scale one is you probably really
want to use a similar batching setup but
we have and the second is in order to
further optimize this we add a caching
layer at the endpoint so that knob each
post request becomes a foul but like
every 10 seconds it flushes out all the
post requests in a single file and cloud
storage so what are some of those
strengths of this setup so as I outline
it's designing a modular way to handle
evolving business needs it's super
simple to start you start with an
endpoint and that right files into cloud
storage you then if your demand like
over time enhances because you run more
playtester you have more players you
could for instance use the cloud
function to help all of those events
over into native bigquery storage or you
can add like a battery set like we did
to like concatenate these files it's a
fewer but larger ones you have a
flexible and custom rest endpoint as an
entry point which is set up to handle
Prince's any event schema or source so
what we've done is we've got a clay fab
event schema parser and just want our
own um thank you vent schema and as
events come in it just figures out which
partial to use and then write everything
in the same format in cloud storage
we also prefer preserved flexibility for
possible so we use new line limit JSON a
blob storage like that's really the key
and we've got kubernetes and docker for
instance utilized where possible we've
used a single language Python 3 which is
very popular in the data community it
will also help like if you've got data
analyst at that kind of engineering
savvy they can also then look at the
pipeline code and understand what's
going on so that's great and it's
affordable because this is deploying
your own clouds kind of delivery model
you avoid any margin that comes with an
off-the-shelf solution so what are some
of the opportunities that we still have
we could reduce the maintenance overhead
by deploying the endpoint for instance
herbalists on cane ADA or cloud run
this way you don't have to manage your
own kubernetes cluster and have the
overhead associated with that you could
also use the endpoint to forward events
to a messaging queue for instance so you
add a method so instead of v1 event
which goes into five storage you do like
v1 stream and it goes I it's a calf car
pops up and if you can use that as a
source for instance the dataflow
streaming job that can keep a rolling
count up say kills and if that spikes or
surges then you can trigger a Blood Moon
in your world so that kind of then
enables this interplay between what the
players do in your ecosystem and how the
ecosystem responds to that on a higher
level so what are some of the weaknesses
of this setup is that it does require a
data engineering capacity to maintain
there is some complexity this is not a
fully managed service the end point will
definitely benefit if you would port it
over to a language like go but at the
cost then again of interpretability for
some of the data folks out there at high
scale you will have a large number of
small files in cloud storage that will
then disable the live external storage
functionality so yeah at that point you
should either use a cult function at the
bathroom step or at the caching layer in
order to like solve for that so threats
we've got an ever evolving data
landscape so with new things that come
out those might challenge that some of
the cities that we've made with this
infrastructure so what are some of the
lessons learned one of the things that
we have right now is our own kind of
event schema so on the wire when you
send this JSON events what is inside of
each events um I'm not gonna list all of
these out one by one you can look at the
slides later and like figure out what
each means but one thing that I wanted
to do explain is that we've kind of
identified these as the only keys that
can be at the top level of your
dictionary anything else would go into
event attributes so for instance if it's
a match start event the match ID would
sit inside of event attributes but by
always having only these kind of keys at
the root level you can safely unpack
these fringes in your first table in the
data warehouse when you ingest that
somewhere and that will dramatically
kind of like simplify the ingestion
frameworks that you have to use if you
want to move that data on going in data
warehouse so about instrumentation
automatically enrich it incoming events
were possible so capture things like the
event timestamp the event index all
automatically only requiring in
developer
to pass in what is unique to that
particular event that's your events
don't send single events like if you can
always backs them up and then at what
rate you can flush those out is informed
by the on the one hand the capacity
you've provisioned for in terms of
requests per second versus the number of
PCs you expect you can kind of then
model out okay well then I'm I can at
most flush X amount of times per seconds
keep a local cache on the client side in
case of connectivity disruptions then
right into a file and then whenever the
connection is reestablish you can flush
everything else
make your ingestion endpoint
configurable so for instance which host
headers or query strings to use for this
particular post request and in
particular the endpoint reads the query
parameters are many of them and they
kind of Co determine the ultimate file
path that the file story needs to Cloud
storage
so you can then basically already
organize and filter out certain event
types and put them in like neatly
structured folders in cloud storage at
this didn't have like beneficial
downstream effects because then I could
write for instance on my frames per
second event to a particular directory
only containing such events and then I
can aggravate those before I write them
in typically for instance in the table
so we're using HTTP endpoints so it's
always good to have reach fast with
exponential back-off if you don't get a
200 code back just like rate them like
take the period and then try again some
of the tips and tricks that we picked up
on as well when actually utilizing this
data is that you can import a Google
spreadsheet as a live bakery table live
meaning if I make change to the
spreadsheet they're instantly visible in
bakery as well and that could be great
for instance if you've got item IDs item
name mapping air tables then vice versa
you can also run big query creation
within google spreadsheets and the
result of that becomes a spreadsheet as
well so this is a great way for business
analysts to still used production data
in victory but in a spreadsheet like
system that they are familiar with you
should also check out the bakery JSON
function to extract data out of event
attributes don't use any of the string
lookup functions just use those
functions because then you just give it
a parsing path and clean me and exactly
like parsing JSON in however you want
also avoid non-alphabetic characters in
JSON keys because that will trip up the
federated query mechanism that I
outlined earlier so then finally we use
DBT to manage
and source control all of our sequel
code as a document everything as well
DBT kind of out of the box makes every
query a model and then you reference
other models which means the entire like
lineage graph or linear system is
preserved with DBT invisible which is
very nice from maintaining all of these
queries and also if you use the schema
dot llamo file you can generate Doc's
just like after box and that will allow
new gate lists that are like just coming
in and they need to get to know your
schema really well it really helped them
to have that as a resource to figure out
how to like run the queries what's a
query which tables to look at it etc
then finally you should also definitely
adopt a gdpr strategy so um two examples
but it's really up to you ultimately
what how you want to approach this but
one could be you add a method to the
endpoint and then you route all your
events that contained personal
identifiable information only to your
data warehouse so you avoid blob storage
because at that point all of that like
data that is sensitive is in a sequel
kind of like ecosystem so you can run
like select star for exports and the
lead from for any forget-me kind of
requests and alternatively if you use
the batching setup what you could do is
you set up a tension policy on the first
bucket for like four to eight weeks and
then when the best we stopped comes in
frames with data flow you have the data
in memory again and that's where you can
then do any scrubbing or anonymous ation
of that data before you move it over
into its final resting place but then
you can kind of like cope with it like
that so that is everything thanks for
watching the video I hope you found
informative and if you have any
questions about it or suggestions then
yeah feel free to go to our website find
out the forms need a question there or
find me on LinkedIn and just like ping
me a message and I will get back to you
[Music]